catherine trudeau la dernière fois qu'on
s'est croisés c'était pour le tapis bleu
de souterrains le film de sophie depuis
qui va enfin sortir en salles le 4 juin
prochain
on a on y on n'y croyait plus ça fait un
an qu'elle file de ce fier près philo
l'oeil et à qui s'envole
c'est l'équipe l'a vu la gagne à val
d'or le vu que géante quel grand public
le voir parce que c'est un film
remarquable qui je pense est acquis
d'ailleurs parlant de cinéma là votre
sortie du conservatoire à 99 je suis
d'après vous avez joué dans l'ange ne
bouderont de dénis chouinard
quels souvenirs gardez-vous cette époque
là où vous vous mettiez vos billets en
place
moi j'ai été invité très très tôt j'ai
cette chance là ça fait 22 ans puis je
mesure encore ma chance dans ma tête ça
fait 4 à kurt l'école oui j'ai encore
cette neige jeudi beaucoup à naïveté
candeur g je prends rien pour acquis
demandez aux films parfois vraiment de
la génération c'était difficile de
personnes
oui en même temps il ya eu une espèce
d'effervescence de rôle à ce moment le
plus de films je reviens à solange de
goudron la loi du cochon québec montréal
y avait beaucoup de projets autour des
25 30 sur une école joseph et capte les
invincibles on a fait ça j'avais 26 27
un écran anti a eu beaucoup c'est une
époque où il y avait beaucoup de séries
ou tour de ma génération où on est rendu
à ce qu'on s'engage est ce qu'on
s'engage pas si j'ai un peu profiter de
cette vague là je dirai non
vous voulez pas qu'on s'appelle et
frozen vomir pour vrai à la télévision
on vivait dans quatre et demi dans
mirador de rupture mais évidemment il
faut parler des invincibles et gagnez un
gémeaux en 2009 grâce aux rodelinda
opportune je suis choyé de le faire avec
des gens de votre talent merci quand
elle apprend aujourd'hui qu'un rôle qui
me colle à la peau mais ça m'embête pas
c'est pas ça me fait plaisir ça me fait
très plaisir
oh oui vraiment parce que l'eau ce qui
est beau c'est que c'est les enfants
guillaume de magazines ceux qui ont eu
des enfants très jeunes
si la honte 15 16 ans de chopin le il
regarde les investitures qui me
reconnaissent voir ben oui c'est pour
cela j'en ai deux je me sens mais pas
assez
la dernière femme capcom est ce que
l'uimm la peau fine pourrait exister en
2021 elles existent encore et je n'ai
pas pris quai je les ai pas inventés
je le dis tout le temps on connaît tous
et toutes
une ligne où on a une ligne intérieure
qu'on essaye de moi je peux avoir une
mémoire
oui je la vois pas encore on se connaît
pas mais si je pense qu'on a tous et
toutes une belle soeur une voisine
camarades de classe une ligne beaucoup
beaucoup mais oui elle existe en 2021
oui vous avez jouer toutes sortes de
rôles et sont fait une petite recherche
sur internet et on tombe sur votre
curriculum vitae dans votre agence
il est écrit en gros et en gras et je
cite bien qu ayant campé plusieurs rôles
de femme intransigeante et sévère
catherine trudeau est reconnu pour sa
personnalité pétillante et joyeuse c'est
ben fayot me la sucer de la jambe
c'est vrai son ouïe plus joyeuse ah oui
si joyeuse et pétillon je sais pas le
sympathique mais ça me rendrait début
mai mais je suis joyeuse mais je suis je
pense que je suis et il ya des gens qui
sont doués pour le bonheur le sait ben
ketai mais c'est moi c'est vrai je me
plais d'un rien je tout le temps où elle
est toute une faune je trouve
désespérant two way j'essaye de cultiver
son jeu réussit pas toujours mais j'ai
une fille joyeuse général pour ça pour
toucher un peu à tout a dû chronique à
l'animation aux stars de la télé du
cinéma sur le fond vous êtes le plus de
gains en se diversifiant
j'ai toujours quelque chose sur le feu
alors que si on choisit des fois un
choix j'ai des amis qui font que du
théâtre n'est ce pas un choix il
aimerait bien en faire de la télé mais
on les choisit pas bons sont pas conviés
tout ce qu'on connaît donc en ayant
développé à travers toutes ces années le
ben oui la chronique l'écriture
l'animation le jeu dans plusieurs
médiums différents mais ça fait que j'ai
toujours quelque chose qui m'occupe et
la l'écriture est née du fait que
j'avais pas de télé pas de radio pas de
petits cinémas pathé a plu qu'est ce qui
est à ma portée que je peux créer
moi-même
quelle histoire je peux raconter
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
continuer de créer c'est l'écriture qui
est arrivé donc c'est ce que ça m'a sur
deux vers 6,4 contre hugo merci les amis
et ses proches
et si on a des jeunes est victime on met
pas en péril la vie des sauveteurs
ki-chun wang lemay crise on aurait pu
marcher plus vite maintenant n'entrevoit
rien comprendre
où s'est posée